hello everyone the 2018 World Chess
Championship is over a Magnus Carlsen is
the world's chess champion once again he
successfully defended his title against
Fabiano Caruana and until the next World
Chess Championship that starts in 2020
that will of course be very interesting
but until then there are plenty of more
chess games to be seen this is one such
game but before we check that out I
would just like to thank everyone for
your extreme support especially on the
day of the last day of the world chess
championship of the tiebreaks that day
my channel received in one day the most
views ever I believe it's over half a
million views in one day so for a chess
channel that's the I don't know that's
the equivalent of 100 million views in a
day for for some other channel so that's
that's really insane so thank you all
for that and we are going back to 1963
now we've already checked up on a couple
of games between grandmasters and some
of the first computer I've already shown
you one game were Bobby Fischer
dismantled the Greenblatt computer
although that computer was a bit bit
stronger but yeah okay I still owe you
two games between fishermen Greenblatt
but this was played between David
Bronson and M 20 M 20 was a Soviet the
digital general-purpose mainframe
computer developed at the Institute of
precise mechanics and Computer
Engineering the program that is being
run on this computer is the boot encode
program developed by vladimir putin co
and in the early days of chess programs
when Ivan Mikhail Botvinnik was going on
about this whole idea boot anko was
actually one of one of both Linux
supporters so here at avid Bronstein
faces this boot anko program run on an M
20 computer and it's very interesting I
guess ok in those days Kings gambit was
a fairly popular opening but when
players were playing these early chess
programs they often played the opening
such as the Kings gambit as in those
days unlike today our engines are just
you know calculating beasts in those
days they were actually calculating was
the
toughest part for the for the program so
let's check out this game it's played in
1963 in the most common mathematics
Institute and David Bronstein everyone's
favorite Grandmaster opens with E 4 we
have E 5 by M 20 and we have not Knight
to f3 but as we've already mentioned the
King's gambit F for M 20 accepts the
gambit we have it captures on f4 Knight
f3 and here Knight to f6 this is a very
nice move in the olden days g5 was the
main line but then after h4 even ideas
like g4 were possible and then why would
often sacrifice a piece here after pawn
captures Queen captures knight c6 let's
say d3 and then white would simply
capture on f4 he would castle and white
would have a fierce attack for the price
of one piece and while this is of course
better for black in the early days of
chess you know chess chess masters
created a beautiful miniatures against
the weaker players using opening such as
this one it's okay we have Knight to f6
p5 now kicking the night away Knight to
g4 and now of course d4 preparing to
capture on f4 and the computer would
pretty much disregards development you
could play something like this X even d5
but he wants to protect DF for pawn so
g5 is being played here we have Knight
to c3 and now comes Knight the e3
offering the trader on e3 and that way
create a very strong pass pawn on e3 if
it most likely it will not be able to
protect it but an interesting move to
say the least and the bronze and doesn't
even capture instead Bronstein goes for
Queen to e2 and okay we have Knight
captures on f1 and again Bronstein
doesn't recapture but there was actually
an even better move here with Queenie to
brunch and actually tests the computer
if computer had a bit more power or if
you know if this was 1974 perhaps most
likely computer would would have played
the g4 and here white would be in some
trouble after captures pawn would
capture here and then after Queen
captures
buttercup on captures and III and after
Bishop to c4 attacking the f7 square
threatening checkmate on f7 white black
could go Queen h4 check block Queen h6
creating an escape route for the King
Gandhi 8 and a while this would be a
very nastic position to actually play
for black you know a strong computer
would be able to defend this you know at
some point he would start developing his
pieces and it will be alright for black
but as we are in 1963 here Knight
captures on f1 was played and Bronson
doesn't even recapture he goes Knight to
e4 and here the computer is very happy
ok
he allows me to retreat with my piece
I'm gonna go back to e3 where the knight
is protected but of course you can see
that this night is coming to f6 at some
point no one would you know willingly do
this but ok we have nice to have 6 check
and now you can either capture with the
Queen and then you of course lose
immediately but King to e7 is played and
here you could go for a bunch of
characters pawn captures Knight chapters
and g5 you can see that white is
completely winning here but again
Bronstein decides to test the
calculating prowess of the m20 we have
Bush up to d2 and now comes Knight
captures and c2 with check the m20 goes
for even more material King to f2 and
now Knight captures on a1 and here we
have Knight to d5 with check King three
six and now our King to e6 is a peculiar
choice if King t8 you would most likely
have to repeat movie or brunch and
wouldn't have anything better here than
to repeat with Knights the d5 check
because you don't really have time to
capture instead of Knight f6 to capture
here after that Bishop e7 is coming
you're controlling the f6 Square now
with the bishop and black would simply
start developing and win the game but
after 95 the computer went King to e6
and here we have Queen the Seaport not
with check but threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries and here trying to
deflect the Queen the m20 plays b5 and
this is the beautiful position that
makes this game what it is we're now
after this b5 move Bronston is actually
threatening a forced checkmate in ten
moves so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this forcing
sequence of moves for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent and major in ten and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show
capturing on b5 doesn't really do
anything c6 attacks the Queen attacks
the knight black wings even more
material and the will very soon win the
game on the other hand if after b5 you
found Knight captures on c7 this is also
winning but it's not a force mate intent
here you with the after king e7 there
should be four check you would at some
point to win the Queen but you would
still have to play on until checkmate
actually occurs so the forcing line
we've mentioned after b5 is actually
Knight captures on g5 and now we have
Queen captures on g5 and now comes
Knight the c7 check and here if you go
to f5 if King a 5 then Queen d3 check
King goes to g4 and Queen to h3 this
will be checkmate
so after Knight to c7 we have King to e7
but now Knight back to defy with chip
and now you really have to decide what
to do here if you go King e8 here then
Queen captures on C it is very nice
after Queen blocks now you get 97 check
King moves and now Bishop to b4 check
you have to block and now Bishop
captures Queen captures and now Queen to
e8 will be checkmate on the other hand
after Knight to d5 if you go King to d8
then this Bishop to a5 check will be
deadly you will have to move the King
Queen captures on c8 again and we will
get a similar idea only a faster one
after Queen captures on d8 this will be
checkmate
so after d5 King has to go back to east
6 now comes Knight captures on f4 this
is very important as you want to clear
this f4 pawn so Bishop captures on g5
will be an option in the future this
again comes with check King to f5 leads
to the exact same checkmate we were
already shown Queen d3 checking moves
and Queen to h3 will be checkmate so
black has to go back King to e7 but now
it's a different story as there is no
more DF for pawn here so nice to d5
check back again but
now the bishop is also attacking the
Queen we have King t8 and now we have f
king t6 again we run into the similar
idea Knight c7 check King e7 mercial
captures f6 and Bushell characters and
f6 this results in checkmate
so after Knight to f4 will King back to
e7 and now nice to d5 again and now we
have King to e8 and here comes Queen
captures and see it a similar ideas
we've already shown Queen has the block
Knight to c7 check King moves Bishop to
b4 check
we have d6 captures captures and the
Queen to e8 and this was checkmate and
this is exactly how the game ended so
this was a one of the checkmates
available in the previous variations
where we've shown but after this f4 pawn
was captured then it was forced and
black had no other ways out so a very
nice miniature in 23 moves by
Grandmaster David Bronson against m20
computer I do hope you enjoyed it and if
I if I if I make the time I will also
show you the two games IOU between Bobby
Fischer and the Greenblatt computer but
yeah very interesting and I will soon
create a poll where you will able be
able to vote for for next series I don't
know there are a couple of things in
mind like you know the couple Blanca
Saga yeah and saga maybe maybe even
something before that maybe you want to
go all the way to morphe anderson saga
or maybe Stein it's Lasker saga or maybe
something more modern like I am at some
point planning to make the return match
between Coulson and Anand but I don't
think that that will be our next saga so
I will have to figure out a couple of
things for so you can you know vote for
the next series but maybe today but if
not most likely tomorrow I would also I
would also like to announce I have a
very special surprise that comes in a
few days well not in a few days maybe in
a week somewhere early in December it
will be a an unannounced series of
videos that you will enjoy immensely and
also I would like to present that as you
can see there is an info corner up there
in
the top left corner where if you have
some interesting news from the world if
you are also perhaps a content creator
and do you have a channel that is able
to increase everyone's vast knowledge
feel free to contact me via email or via
any social network and you know if I
enjoy your content if I decide it's
quality content
I will advertise it for free so everyone
can enjoy that as well so that's
basically it I would like to thank
William Miller Alex a true bits in Chris
Picard the Jeff blights and William
Fusco for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thing called for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you all and once again
congratulations to everyone who found
the forced checkmate intent sequence see
you soon